also heute
strecke mich der Teig richtig an
ich sag's dir heute bin ich fix und
fertig nach dem Teig
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen tomaten-mozzarella
Pesto Strudel was richtig schnelles
einfach ist und zwar haben wir noch ganz
viele Tomaten aus dem Garten ihr
vielleicht auch und falls nicht könnt
ihr euch ja noch mal Tomaten holen denn
der Strudel der ist einfach ist schnell
sättigend und furchtbar lecker später
serviere ich dazu einfach im Salat und
dann haben wir ein leckeres Gericht ich
werde das Ganze aus einem Quark-Öl-Teig
machen weil man den eben ganz einfach
zubereiten kann und sofort
weiterverarbeitet anders als bei
Hefeteig der eben vorher aufgehen muss
wenn ihr aber sagt ihr wollt euch die
Arbeit auch sparen könnt ihr natürlich
auch einen fertigen Blätterteig nehmen
einen fertigen Hefeteig also ihr könnt
schon auch gucken weil immer mal wieder
viele sagen mach doch mal einfache
Rezepte oder was mit bisschen
Fertigprodukten aber ich bin halt nicht
so der Fertigprodukte Typ aber wenn ihr
das seid alles gut ich habe früher auch
viel Pizzateig aus dem Kühlfach geholt
mit dem Murat erinner ich mich dran
haben wir immer so eine Rolle geholt und
dann einfach Pizza belegt weil wir
einfach die Zeit nicht hatten und ich
halt auch noch nicht so im Kochen war
muss ich sagen das kam mir so nach und
nach deswegen entweder Quark-Öl-Teig
oder Hefeteig oder ihr nehmt was aus dem
Kühlfach was auch völlig okay ist für
den Quark-Öl-Teig nehme ich 300 Gramm
Mehl plus Backpulver oder ihr verwendet
das backmehl etwas Salz und Pfeffer 150
Gramm Quark 40 Gramm Olivenöl und ein Ei
das war es schon das Gute am
Quark-Öl-Teig ist alle Zutaten kommen in
die Rührschüssel und werden einfach nur
miteinander verknetet da gibt es keine
Reihenfolge da gibt es kein richtig oder
falsch sondern einfach nur alles rein
geht auch schnell per Hand oder eben mit
dem Handrührgerät
bei Salz finde ich es immer wichtig ich
habe immer diese Messlöffel und gebe
wirklich Gewürze immer ganz exakt den
Messlöffeln an weil ich nämlich finde
dass viele zu wenig Salz benutzen an der
richtigen Stelle also gerade bei Teigen
ist schon wichtig dass man die richtige
Salzmenge nimmt weil sonst schmeckt
einfach Fahrt und das habe ich schon
öfter beobachtet dass man einfach zu
sparsam mit Salz umgeht ich weiß zu viel
Salz ist nicht gesund aber gerade bei
Teigen sollte man schon die richtige
Salzmenge wählen nicht überwürzen und
deswegen messe ich das immer exakt mit
Messlöffeln ab damit ihr da einfach die
richtige Menge habt ansonsten in Salaten
oder in Soßen könnt ihr ruhig mal auch
mal ein bisschen weniger nehmen Salz
kommt so ein bisschen reduzieren und das
sage ich bei Gemüse mag ich es auch ganz
gerne dass man dann nicht so übersalzt
aber gerade bei Teigen die schmecken
halt echt Fahrt wenn man da zu wenig
Salz nimmt auch bei Nudeln zum Beispiel
deswegen achtet da schon drauf
ja bei allem anderen was eben so ein
eigenen Geschmack hat Gemüse und so
weiter das könnte ja dann weniger Salzen
wenn ihr darauf verzichten wollt
aber nicht bei Teig auch nicht besser
Hefeteig da ist auch Salz wichtig dass
es schmeckt
[Musik]
und nur kurz verrühren
der Teig ist jetzt fertig den Rest knete
ich nämlich einfach gleich per Hand
zusammen aber ich richte jetzt schon mal
die Zutaten für die Füllung und zwar
kommt da jetzt ein tomatenpesto rein da
gibt es ein Rezept schon auf meinem
Kanal Tomaten und Mozzarella deswegen
werde ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen wie es
Tomaten Pesto hergestellt wird denn da
könnt ihr einfach in meiner App
nachschauen
oder auch ein fertiges tomatenpesto
verwenden
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier meinen
Teig ich habe hier einen tomatenpesto
hergestellt da könnt ihr gerne das
Shorts von gestern anschauen und auch
das real da habe ich euch noch mal die
Zubereitung gezeigt und das Rezept
findet ihr einfach in meiner App das
sind jetzt etwa 200 Gramm zwei Bällchen
Mozzarella und ein paar Tomaten das
war's schon und ich nehme jetzt hier den
Teig der wird jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
einfach mit den Händen zusammen geknetet
dann passt es auch schon
[Musik]
ich halbe jetzt den Teig
und lass den hier kurz stehen und kann
so lange Mozzarella und Tomaten schön in
Scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
dann rolle ich den Teig jetzt schön
rechteckig aus und wenn ihr jetzt
fertigen Blätterteig nehmt dann ist er
ja schon rechteckig
[Musik]
ich glaube der wird mir zu klein wenn
ich zwei mache ich doch einen Strudel
mehr werden zwei Strudel zugleich ich
mache einen großen
[Musik]
also heute
strecke mich der Teig richtig an
ich sag's dir heute bin ich fix und
fertig nach dem Teig
so
ich finde irgendwie
und wenn ihr hier die Seiten immer mal
ein klappt dann habt ihr auch nur so
eine schöne gerade
so sieht er jetzt wunderbar aus
und jetzt werde ich hier die Mitte
belegen und für den Geschmack sorgt
einfach das Pesto da müsste dann nämlich
nichts mehr würzen und alles schmeckt
wunderbar
aber das ist ein bisschen viel ich
glaube 200 Gramm zu viel wir nehmen die
Hälfte 100 g
[Musik]
wie so ein Baggerfahrer
so ein Rezept ich mache das ja im Video
jetzt auch zum ersten Mal wie so oft bei
den Rezepten und deswegen ich glaube es
passt doch wenn ich euch im Blog dann
immer die richtige Menge angeht weil
eben habe ich gerade 200g Pesto ich
brauche es doch nur 100 weil es besser
passt dann gebe ich euch einen Blog
einfach an 100 Gramm Pesto
Gott und jetzt einfach Tomate und
Mozzarella hier schön reinschichten
und das liebe ich am kochen da bin ich
so ein bisschen frei und kann dann
einfach währenddessen immer mal gucken
wie es passt
[Musik]
wenn ihr wollt könnt jetzt noch ein
bisschen Pesto obendrauf geben
so für bisschen mehr Geschmack
und dann schneide ich das ganze jetzt
ein und zwar will ich das ganze so ein
bisschen drüber Falten das heißt hier
oben nach außen schneiden hier nach
außen und hier unten auch
und die Seiten werden jetzt wie so ein
Fächer geschnitten
[Musik]
dann oben einklappen und unten
einklappen
und hier immer einmal von links und
einmal von rechts
[Musik]
so da packe jetzt noch Käse drauf und
dann kommt es in den Backofen das wird
so oder so lecker
Salat dazu fertig
gut dass ich Käse eingefroren habe
[Musik]
in den Ofen
da guck mal jetzt mal also richtig gut
[Musik]
das sieht einfach super gut aus gerade
irgendwie in die falsche Kamera geguckt
dazu gibt es jetzt bei uns einen Salat
da mache jetzt gleich noch ein Dressing
dazu ich würde sagen wir schneiden den
aber schon mal direkt an
und jetzt darf probiert werden
riecht schon gut gell
ist da alles drin Tomate Mozzarella
ich glaube Ella wird die neue
Verkäuferin in meinen Videos
eine Frage ich und was ist dein Beruf
dann sagst du Hobby Verkostungen
was meint wie viele Menschen dich um den
Job beneiden
noch mal
richtig gut
aber ich würde bei mir jetzt noch ein
Chiliöl drauf machen auf jeden Fall
Chili Olivenöl bei uns gibt es jetzt
diesen Strudel dazu einen leckeren Salat
und das Ganze ist wirklich sehr schnell
zubereitet wie ihr sehen könnt ich habe
sie aus diesem Quark-Öl-Teig zubereitet
aber ihr könnt auch gerne ein
Pizzateig einfach aus dem Kühlfach
nehmen oder Blätterteig wenn ihr möchtet
das Rezept findet ihr wenn Ella esse
weiter empfiehlt in meiner App empfehlst
du das Rezept weiter
gut dann gibt es ab jetzt in meiner App
bis zum nächsten Mal und schreibt doch
mal ganz gerne was ich als nächstes
machen soll ich habe mir schon gedacht
dass Mama wieder so eine nachgemacht
Kategorie machen denn es gibt ja auch
viele herzhafte Gerichte die man
nachmachen kann entweder mal wieder so
ein Maggi Fix schreibt mir das dann
gerne weil dann müssen wir extra dafür
einkaufen gehen oder zum Beispiel wenn
ihr von irgendwo was herzhaftes kennt
das hat mich zum Beispiel auch ein
bisschen an diese früher gab es ich weiß
nicht ob es noch gibt diese
ikea-brötchen mit Tomate Mozzarella
gegeben dann schreibt mir das dann
probieren wir das aus und dann gibt's im
nachgemacht Rezept bis bald tschüss
[Musik]